[Music]
foreign
welcome back okay things are getting
pretty exciting we are now getting very
comfortable with solving second order
linear differential equations things
like the equations that come from f
equals m a of a mass on a spring and
today we're going to take a big step to
generalize into a much more Broad and
Powerful class of differential equations
of higher order so instead of just
having a first or a second derivative in
time now we're going to be able to deal
with systems with three or four or n
arbitrarily many degree
derivatives of of my state of my system
in time so that's what I mean by higher
order ordinary differential equation is
when the differential equation has more
time derivatives than just one or two
okay so I'll write down kind of the
generic system I'm thinking about so
we're thinking about having you know DX
uh DT that's just the first derivative
of my state of my system with respect to
time but now we're going to talk about
taking the nth derivative of of the
state of the system with respect to time
maybe that'll have some coefficient a n
plus a n minus 1 the N minus oneth
derivative of x with respect to T N
minus 1 I'm just going to write out kind
of the generic nthorter higher order
ordinary differential equation and then
we'll analyze it
plus dot dot dot plus
um and then at some point I have you
know a two
D squared x d t squared that's the
second derivative with respect to time
plus A1 DX DT
plus a 0 x equals zero so any kind of
um
nth order derivative system you can
write like this in terms of these these
kind of linear coefficients A1 a0 A2 all
of these A's are just numbers and these
are my derivatives of the state of my
system with respect to time okay so this
is a generic nth order or higher order
ordinary differential equation and up
until now we've only been looking at
first order and second order
differential equations and we've guessed
Solutions like e to the Lambda T's X of
T equals e to the Lambda T plug them in
and figured out what Lambda had to be so
we're going to do the exact same thing
here
um they're shorthand sometimes that I
use to to write this so there's an
alternative or
um you can also write this as there's a
shorthand where sometimes you just write
um
you know so I would write this
um
a and when I write X kind of in
parentheses n that usually means the nth
time derivative plus a n minus one
um
times x the N minus 1 time derivative
it's very hard to erase this without
erasing everything
minus 1 x n minus 1 plus dot dot dot
plus
a two x double dots plus a 1 x dot plus
X
times the coefficient a 0 equals zero so
this is like an alternative shorthand
where instead of DX DT I write x dot and
instead of D squared x DT for the second
derivative I write X double dot and x
triple dot would be the third derivative
and once I stop being able to write you
know I can't write n dots so I just say
x to the power parentheses n this just
means n time derivatives of X so these
are just two different ways of writing
this higher order system so I'm going to
come back to solving this in a minute
um but I want to give you just a really
simple gut feeling for how you can get
these higher order systems so we know
that f equals m a like Newton's Second
Law
um f equals m a gives me second order
systems pretty easily because my
acceleration is the second derivative of
my position so if I'm measuring you know
the position of uh
this Mass on a spring as it evolves in
time let's say there's some rest
position here which I'm going to call x
equals zero so I pull this Mass down I
stretch out my Straight spring I let it
go and it starts oscillating okay that
is
um you know governed by f equals m a and
a acceleration is just X double dot so
really easy to get a second order system
you know here or here how do I get these
higher derivatives in a way that makes
sense and this is actually really really
simple so the the easiest thing you
could do is just add another Mass okay
so add another spring
add another Mass so now this is you know
M2 K2 M1 K1
and this will be X1 and let's say that
this thing also has a rest position uh
you know from here this will also have a
rest position and this will be X2
of T so so right away now I have a a
system of you know two variables X1 and
X2 and what I'm going to show you now is
that you can write this down as a a
fourth derivative system okay and if I
added another Mass I would get a system
with six derivatives if I had another
Mass I could get a system with eight
derivatives and kind of interesting if I
actually
um
think about a you know if I think about
a little mesh or infinite
uh array
of masses on Springs and maybe I could
even make it 2D
I could pretty quickly I could take the
limit as the spacing between these
becomes arbitrarily small
and as I you know get arbitrarily many
of these things I can make this kind of
a very big array of masses on Springs
very close together and this is actually
going to be a pretty good model for a
tight membrane like the surface of a
drum okay so if you want to you know
play a drum we will in future lectures
in in the next you know you know weeks
from now we'll model that using the 2D
wave equation okay the the wave equation
but you could think of that as coming
from this kind of discrete element
method where you write down a bunch of
little masses on Springs connected to
each other and kind of take the limit as
they become very very close and kind of
infinitesimal okay and in that case you
would get a huge system of ordinary
differential equations of many many you
know higher order
and that would be approximating a
physical system so I'll come back to
that later
um no big deal that that kind of went
over over your head so let's talk about
this system here so pretty easy to write
down the differential equation region
here we will have something like
Mass 1 X1 double dot plus spring
constant One X One
um
[Music]
ah yeah this thing is also getting a
force Mass one I'm looking at my notes
and getting befuddled this Mass has a
force from this spring but it also has a
force from this spring so it also has
plus K2
um
X1 minus X2 so kind of when this thing
is if this thing moves up or if this
thing moves down that creates an
extension of this spring so that's uh X
1
minus X2
that equals zero this is not a physics
class this is a math class so you know
exactly the details of how I write down
the the f equals m a is not the
important thing it's what happens next
so that's for this equation now for this
equation this mass m 2 x 2 double dot
I'm assuming no damping here but you
could add damping plus k
2 times x 2 minus x 1 equals zero
similarly this thing gets pulled up if
its displacement is large or if m1's
displacement is large in the negative
Direction okay and so this is a system
of two coupled
second order equations so I'm just going
to say that this is
a system
of two
coupled
second
order
Odes
okay so they are coupled because the X1
equation depends on X1 and X2 and the X2
equation depends on X1 and X2 so they're
coupled they're intrinsically linked
it's a system because there's two of
these equations two coupled equations
and each of them is second order because
they have second time derivatives okay
so this is a system of two coupled
second order Odes
now it would be very easy to write this
as a system
of four
coupled
first order Odes
and I'm trying to get you comfortable
with the fact that it's easy to kind of
go
from
um
two systems of second order equations to
a system of four first order equations
or a single
fourth order equation okay so I'm going
to show you all of these so what you
could do is you could introduce a new
variable you could say you know I have
X1
X1 Dot X2
X2 Dot and you could Define you know
those as the state of a new system you
could literally you know create this
Vector that was X1 V1 X2 V2
and you would write down that system dot
equals some big a matrix
times uh you know that state X1 V1 X2
V2 so just like we've done for for
second order systems for the second
order system and for this one you can do
it for the coupled system and so
actually I would like you to this is a
great homework exercise so I would like
you to kind of maybe pause here and try
to transform this system of equations
these two coupled second order equations
into four coupled first order equations
their first order now because there's
only one time derivative there's only
one DDT
so you know the X1 double dot is V1 Dot
and the X2 double dot is V2 dot so I've
turned these second derivatives into
first derivatives by adding new
variables you can do that okay
um
so that's One Direction and then the
other direction is
that you can write this as a single
fourth order
order ode meaning I can write this as a
single ordinary differential equation in
terms of a single variable but now that
single variable is going to have fourth
derivatives in that expression and I'm
again I'm going to tell you how to do
that and then I'm going to ask you to do
that okay so um you know because we're
eventually going to want to get a system
like this so
um
how do we do that so what we're going to
do so the the procedure here maybe I'll
erase this and I'll just write it out
the procedure here
is
we're going to solve the first equation
let's call this one
and let's call this two
we're going to solve the first equation
for X2 as a function of all of these X
ones
and then we're going to plug that in to
the second equation okay
so we're going to solve uh we're going
to solve equation one
for x 2 equals some big nasty function
of all of the you know X1 X1 dot X1
double dot
it's not that nasty of a function it's
just you know all of this stuff
then what we're going to do
um
is we're going to take two derivatives
of that
so step this is Step a step B is now
take
two derivatives
of you know x two double dot we're
literally going to take this function
and take two derivatives so now that's
going to be some other function G and
because this had X1 double dots now it's
going to have X1 quadruple dot so it's
going to be in terms of X1 X1 dot X1
double dot X1 triple dot X
one
quadruple dot which I'm going to write
as you know superscript 4. okay and now
the last part C
is we're going to plug
in
to equation
two into this equation two we're going
to plug that x2 in here
um
this expression here we're also going to
plug this expression for x2 in here and
now we're going to have something that's
only in terms of X1 and its fourth
derivatives so that will give me a
single fourth order ode and in general
you can always do this you can always go
from a system of four coupled first
order equations to a single fourth order
you can always go from a single fourth
order to a coupled system
to four uh coupled first order and you
can do these intermediates so these are
all completely equivalent systems and
you'll notice that you know these two
second order systems that multiplies to
four or a single fourth order that
multiplies to four or a system of four
first order that multiplies to four so
those are are all the ways you can kind
of kind of group this
um
maybe I'll just do this I think what I'm
going to do is I'm actually going to
show you how to do this and end the
video you know there and then we're
going to revisit these higher order
systems in the next video so I'm
actually going to show you how to write
this as a fourth order system
um
well uh pitter patter so I'm going to
move my X2 over and divide by K2 so I'm
going to say X2
if I solve equation 1 for X2 I'm going
to say X2
equals everything on the left
which is
M1 X1 double dot
plus K1
x one
Plus
K2 X1
K2 X1
and I moved my X2 times K2 over and I'm
going to divide by K2 so this is you
know 1 over K2 1 over K2 you know this
is divided by K2
and so this whole thing equals m one
shoot over K2
M1 over K2 maybe I'll do it right here
this is uh M1 over K to X1 double dot
plus K1 over K2 X
1 dot plus uh x one that's what x two
equals okay good so we've isolated X2
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take its second derivative this isn't
that bad actually because I just
literally add dots to these that's all
because these are constants out front M1
K2 K1 and K2 are all constants
so now uh x 2 double dot is just
M1 over K2 X1 quadruple Dot
plus K1 over K2 X1 triple dot plus x one
double dot
and now the last step this is really
easy is I take you know this expression
for X2 double dot and this expression
for X2 which are now only expressed in
terms of X1 and I guess I can pick
either of these equations probably this
equation and I yeah definitely the
second equation and I plug them in and
I'll have something that's my final
answer so
where should I do that
I'll do that in green this was a this
was B and now step C
I plug them into this equation and I'm
literally going to have m 2 x double dot
so that's m
2
times all of this stuff so M2 M1 over K2
X quadruple X1 quadruple Dot
plus m
2
K1 over K2 X1 triple Dot
plus m
2 x 1 double dot that's just this term
plus this stuff now okay plus
K2
times X2
is going to be m 1 x 1 double dot Plus
K1
X1 dot Plus
K2 X1 okay that's this term
minus K2 X1 all of that equals zero and
now I can kind of just group terms and
you know make sure I put all of my X
double dots together and I get something
really simple which is essentially
um
some constant it doesn't matter what
constant this is m2m1
over K2 times x one fourth derivative
plus another constant M2 over K2 X1
triple dot plus another constant which
is just m one plus m 2 x 1 double dot
plus uh
K1 x dot plus k
I think my k2s cancel uh interesting I
think these actually cancel out unless I
messed up something
that might be true okay
um
you can double check my math I very well
could have made a mistake I like don't
have notes for this and I just kind of
did this on the Fly you know plus zero
times x equals zero so
this is just you know it took me about
five minutes and I went from this system
of two coupled second order equations to
a single
fourth order equation just in X1 okay
and good homework for you would be to do
the exact same thing but now try to
write this isolate the X2 variable right
this is a fourth order equation in the
X2 variable you would do basically the
exact same thing you would pick an
equation now solve for X1 as a function
of X2 take its derivatives and plug it
into the other equation you'll get
another system like this okay so easy to
do this to go from this system to
less variables but higher order or to go
to more variables but lower order
okay in the next lecture we're going to
now that we have this under our belt now
we're going to really start analyzing
what do we do with these higher order
systems how do we solve them how do we
analyze them all right that's coming up
thank you
[Music]